Ave Maria Grazia plena dominus stick
Benedetta tu i mulieribus and I bless you
exploit guttrii
now just spectators not that until now
dead our real Ave Maria Grazia
plena domino's techum Benedetta tu i
mulieribus et benedictus fruit Sven
Tris tui and Asus Santa Maria
Ora now spectatorsbus not understood
and spirit and Holy
and in six with the axis with them never
[Music]
[Applause]
slightly
surprising
until the night But it's not worth
and I was
avocado ours
and our
return of the Fire
l  the year disappears
[Music]
In a few moments the
celebration of the passion of the Lord will begin
we welcome the entry of the Holy Father in
absolute silence
the Celebration of the Lords Fashion
Will begin in a Fiume Moments
Company the Holy fathers and trends
incomplete Silence
and is about to comment on the celebration
of the Passion of the Lord
we will prepare our furnishings From the Hypermanescan Holy
Father
during the professional
entrance in absolute silence
a Domine and we make the stuos eternal
sanctifying protection for which I scristus
sonstosi person
from the book of the prophet Isaiah
Here is my  servant will be successful he
will be honored
exalted and exalted greatly
as many were amazed at him he was so
disfigured to be a Cathedral his
appearance
is different his form from that of the
sons of men so
many Nations will marvel at him
the king will close before him  the
mouth
because they will see a fact never told to them
and will understand what they had never
heard
who would have believed our announcement
to whom the arm of the Lord would have been revealed
has grown like a shoot before
him and like a root in arid earth it
has no appearance  nor beauty to
attract our gazes,
nor splendor to please us,
despised and rejected by men, a man
of sorrows who knows suffering well,
like someone before whom we cover our
faces, he
was despised and we had no
respect
for him. Yet He took charge of our
sufferings he
took on our pains
and we judged him
chastised by God and humiliated
he was pierced for our
sins crushed for our iniquities
The punishment that gives us salvation
fell on him for his wounds
We were healed
we were all lost like a
flock,
each of us followed our own path,
the Lord
made
the iniquity of us all fall upon him, he was
mistreated, he allowed himself to be humiliated and did not
open his mouth, he
was like a lamb led to the slaughter,
like a sheep that is silent before its own
shearers
and did not open his mouth
with oppression it is unjust sentence
he who grieves for his posterity was
eliminated Yes he was eliminated from the land of the living
for the sin of my people he was beaten
to death
he was given burials with the wicked with
the rich  it was his Mound
Although he had committed no violence
Nor was there deceit in his mouth
but the lord was pleased to prostrate him with
pains
when he offers himself as a sacrifice
of reparation
He will see a descendant he
will live long
the will of the Lord will be fulfilled through him
after his  intimate torment will see the
light and will be satisfied with its knowledge
my righteous servant will justify many
He will bear their iniquities
therefore I will live as a reward for the multitudes
of the mighty he will take spoil
because he has stripped himself to the point of
death and has been numbered among the wicked
while he bore the sin of many
and interceded for the guilty
a verb
adollar
[Music]
in your hands with a sign my spirit
my spirit
Lord I have taken refuge I will never be
disappointed
Defend me for your justice
to your hands I
entrust the  my spirit
you have redeemed me lord god Faith
good
[Music]
with sign my spirit
I am the rejection of my enemies and
even of my neighbors
the
terror of my acquaintances
Who sees me on the street
[Music]
I am like a dead man far from the heart
I am  like a shard to cast around
[Music]
my spirit
But I trust in you Lord I
say You are my God my days
are in your hands
free me from the hand of my enemies
And from my persecutors
[Music]
on your  servant make your face shine
Save me by your
Mercy
Be strong
make your heart firm
All of you who hope in the Lord
[Music]
when I feel my breath [
Music] [Music] [Music
] [
Music]
[Music]
[  Music]
[Music] [
Music] [Music] [Music] [Music] [Music] [
Music] [
Music]
[Music]
[Music] I
serve
as a court acciapisset
and among pontificals Busseto to be 6x
minister
[  Music]
come the look with lanterns in set
facilebus and
water weapons Ventura was a superhero
trials
and you say
about yourself
when you ask
I will answer a tea
[Music]
says
here between you and beats a rally
or back of XI I'll follow you on
abiere  a retroarch and Cecilia
[Music]
[Music] [
Music] [
Music]
or timplare
[Music] [
Music]
was
tatamment servant to the course
nexite proud
hospital code
[Music]
tribune set ministers you de Oro
understand
[Music]
[  Music]
follows matured
[Music]
and such obstruct
Saudi disciple
[Music]
on in other difficult moments [
Music]
Petrus autem Stabat in Austin
[Music]
Viterbo
discipulusarius here was atmosphere
and I'll introduce you
[Music] I
mention
petroncillati
not here  no one
[Music]
ministers here for a kind of
like the seven Pedro small
rooms easy stairs
[Music]
questionable and sun in the
disciplice
at the doctrina
[Music]
and with always yours here in the Synagogue and blue shades
like
Jewish conferences
internet
Tino cult locotosogni
[Music]
quidmail integer
Smallpox here I will hate in that cutuzzo
[Music]
S
assistance minister Run dedicates the
family
[Music]
dirty
difficult respondents
reply You are
[Music]
idiot I talk to
witnesses a perimeter
[Music] [
Music]
[  Music]
[Music] [
Music] [Music
] [
Music]
in your contact me and his mother
in the pretorium
[Music]
take a timp Praetorian
or you don't
contaminate her if I send care and Pasca
Exe Viterbo pilot used or sporas and you
say
man
accusation  but open
[Music]
xerunty
[Applause] [
Music] [
Music] [Music
] [Music] [
Music] [
Music]
Reply Reply
[Music] [
Music]
inside
[Music]
a non-being world
[  Music]
Reply Reply
[Music]
voice
of the pilots
[Music] [
Music]
and with one I Invenio in the era
[Music]
bis Oh you don't limit yourself in you I
get very kneaded
[Music]
[Applause]
[  Music]
[Music]
[Music] [
Music] [
Music] [Music] [Music] [Music] [
Music]
a pontiff set ministers
sensational of people
[Music]
a good set crucifying you
Ergo and Mimmo  in euro what
[Music]
answer a Teide
[Applause]
[Music]
how was guardists
a Sermoneta
but you stimulate us
and I always enter you your arrival
miterum
Edit city of it
[Music]
saotem response you don't have to
citargo to the
pilatus
undermining that
ry
nescis here to protest
evil
and you can Evil crucify
[Music]
Reply
Don't have power But really on me
ass
nisiti vs
[Music]
promoter
Here you find
[Music] [
Music] [
Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music] [
Music] [
Music] [Music
] [
Music]
I will answer a Papal
[Music]
concargo tradi of
tessillon of crucify
[Music]
on that for a Turkish
CB Cross ex
civitateum Here you say Turkish the various
Jewish heart locun you say the Golgotha
is a crucifix
[Music]
a bald
super cross
[Music]
but many light I will not close
here
apropecivitate but it was too Locus
Ubi crucifixus
[Music]
Latin Jewish cryptum Greece
says Walter gopinato pontiff  it closes
now
[Music]
If my love you are here now
reply full you quo I'm going to sign up
sign up
[Music]
Melita sergò with a crucifixes feel up
for an investment
they made a
four part Unique
part and tunic
was tatam tunic in
consultings in the  his percontex is open
you
dixerunt Ergo to index
[Music] [
Music] [
Music]
Maria Maddalena
convi said I have a
discepoloom instantaneously therefore I said
[Music] [
Music] [
Music]
[Music]
but you marry tumerata full vinegar
let's show
[Music]
the above
circumponent obsolerentorie
[Music]
perceived silent
his ostix
[Music]
I incline you yours I understood
I of the Ergo heart to a parascevera
put not to remain in cross corpora Saturday
was tender magnosties the book Sabatini
drug to have a  stapled
utfrangerentoreorum cure and everything
else military
[Music]
[Music] [
Music]
and continuous Excite blood silk
[Music]
acquabit witnesses a periduit stop [
Music]
facta sunt animal
S scriptural [Music] [Music] [
Music]
[Music]
[Music] [Music
] [
Music]
in the ass not here
like this you are evening
you monument
[Music]
fathers brothers and sisters
for two thousand years the church announces and
celebrates On this day
the death of the son of God on  cross
at every mass after the Consecration and know I
proclaim your death lord we
proclaim your Resurrection
While awaiting your coming
another death of God however has been
proclaimed for a century and a half to today
in our
secularized Western world
when in the context of  culture we
talk about the death of God
and this other ideological non-historical death of God
which is understood by
some theologians In order not to fall behind
the times they rushed
to build a theology on top of it
the theology of the death of God we
cannot pretend to ignore
the existence  of this different narrative
Without leaving many believers prey to suspicion,
this different death of God has found
its perfect expression
in the well-known proclamation that Nietzsche the
philosopher puts in the mouth of the mad man
who arrives breathless in the city square.
Where did God go he shouted to you  I say, it
was we who killed him, you and I, there
was never a greater action,
all those who come after us
will belong by virtue of this action
to a higher history than
all the stories up to now have ever been
In logic  of these words
and I believe in their author's expectations
there was that after him history
would no longer be divided into before Christ and
after Christ but before he says and after he says
apparently it is not nothingness that is
put in place of God But the  man,
more precisely the superman or the beyond
man
of this new man must now be exclaimed
with a feeling of satisfaction and
pride, not of compassion and there is man.
Here is the true man,
however, it will not take long to realize that
only the  man is nothing
that we have ever done to untie this
earth from the chain of its sun
continues the Madman the madman Where is he
moving now you
must we move away from all the
suns it
is not ours an eternal fall and
backwards  from side to side on
all sides
there is still a high and a low
are we not wandering as if through
an infinite nothingness
the silent and reassuring answer
of the mad man to these questions of his is
no we will not pay in an infinite nothingness
because the man will absolve  him the task
assigned up to now to God
our answer as believers is
yes
and that is exactly what happened and what
is happening
We are wandering as if through an
infinite nothing
is significant that precisely in the wake of the author
of that program
we have come to define
human existence A being for death
and to consider all the supposed
possibilities of man
of nonentities departing
Beyond good and evil was
another battle cry of this
philosopher
But beyond good and evil there  'it is only
the will to power
and we know well where it leads
where it is leading us
there is no right to judge the heart of a
man who only God knows
even the author of that program has
had his share of suffering in
life
and  suffering unites us to Christ perhaps
more than invectives separate
him from him
the prayer of Jesus on the cross father
Forgive them because they do not know what
they do
was not pronounced only for those who
were present that day on Calvary
an image comes to mind that  I have
sometimes observed live
and which I hope has become reality in the
meantime for the author of that program,
an angry child
tries to hit his father in the face with his fists and fats
until, having exhausted his strength, he falls crying
into the arms of his father who calms him down. And
if he holds it to his chest
we do not judge the person, I repeat,
only God knows
the outcome, but that program has
had
that, yes, we can and must judge it
and if it has been expressed in the
most diverse ways and names to the point
of becoming a fashion
The atmosphere that reigns in the
intellectual environments of the postmodern West
and the common denominator of all these
different declinations is total
relativism
in every field, epic language, philosophy,
art and, of course, religion,
nothing is solid anymore, everything is liquid or
even vaporous.
In the time of Romanticism, we
basked in melancholy
today in nihilism
as believers and our duty
to show what is behind or beneath that
proclamation
and that is the flicker of an ancient flame
sudden eruption of a volcano never
extinguished since the beginning of the world
the human drama has also had
his prologue in heaven
in that spirit of denial
and did not accept to exist thanks to another
since then he has only recruited
supporters of his cause
first among them the naive Adam and Eve
you will be like God
you will know good and evil
to man  modern All this seems like nothing more
than an etiological myth
to explain the evil of the world
and in the positive sense that is given today to the
word Vito, this is what it actually is.
But history,
literature
and our personal experience
tell us that behind this myth there is  a
transcendent truth that no
historical narration or
philosophical reasoning could convey to us
God knows our pride and
came to meet us,
annihilating himself first before
our eyes
Christ Jesus despite being of a Divine nature I
do not consider his
equality with God a jealous treasure
But he stripped himself if  himself
assuming the condition of a servant and
becoming similar to men
appeared in human form He humbled himself by
becoming obedient until death
and death on the Cross
God it was we who killed him you and
I cries the mad man
this terrible thing has in fact
happened  once in human history
but in a very different sense from the one intended
by him
because it is true brothers and sisters
it was us you and I who killed
Jesus of Nazareth
and he died for our sins
and for those of the whole world.
But his  Resurrection assures us that
this road does not lead to defeat
but with our repentance leads to
that apotheosis of life
sought in vain elsewhere.
Why talk about this during the
Good Friday liturgy
not to convince atheists that God
is not dead,
the most famous among them  They discovered it on their
own
the moment they closed their
eyes to the light or rather the darkness of
this world
as for those among them still alive, far
other means are needed to convince
than the words of an old preacher
means that the Lord does not  it will make
those with open hearts miss the truth as
we will ask God Soon in
universal prayer
no the real purpose is another
and to hold believers back
Who knows maybe just some university students
from being drawn into this
vortex of nihilism which is the real
black hole  of the spiritual universe
makes the
ever timely admonition of our Dante
Alighieri resonate among us,
be Christians to move more seriously,
do not be like a pen in every wind and do not
believe that every water washes you, let
us continue, venerable fathers, brothers and
sisters
to repeat with moved gratitude and
more convinced than ever
the words we proclaim at every mass
we announce your death lord
we proclaim your resurrection
While waiting for your coming
[Music] to
pacify to honor and safeguard dignity
Totò
[Music]
bisqueta and tranquil mendita A
decentibus glorify a powerful heritage
custodians work Mercy
and end in confession to your names
We would like a set Pro beatissimo
Our Pope Francis
[Music]
Salvo
matquein coloman
custody Tech Ecclesiae nuns
adrendo un popolo un santomè
restice e Capricciosa
etmail.com continue pity expensive or
christian plems when he makes me get off the
your Providence as you exist trust its
merits because no one dominates ours
we would like setopromnibus episcopice
presbiteris away with the universal buckets
[Music]
a body secclesia and sanctified the
income and grant our Promessi Sposi
sublicantis or thanks to your walls to your
men distrust savianthus
because I  I'm going to one of our
[Music]
memories
for the Vacuum regenerations
accept omnium mission
sinful and tips for sale
[Music]
every power
with options his sons Agrigento for
all our
in Christ a believer on TV
set dominus nosters
verite but  easy easily
in an ecclesia its
congregate
guard dignity
Omni power
who dispersed with the second tied
preservas Greece infinite of appeased
is understood or each drummer
sacraris FIDAS integritas and zinc non
society caritatis because Christ is a
dominus
proyo
Days dominus stevos nostère and the
distributors
and you  insulted Federi limited challenges and
try
Omni power
that promises Stua Sabra and Husky
sow controlists and reset Clemente
rexaudi or the people know acquisitions
superior to various
entrepreneurial relationships to come for Christ a
dominus
here in cristom I don't believe
light Santis witty illustrated
Vim health
and tipsy is worth  even within the
fact that Christ Not competent
fortieth in heaven strings ambulantes
in worthy deserved hidden very
proficient always love and between two
lives mysterium Plinius per cdn non
sollecitus perfection sefice your
texts Downloaded on the world for Christ does not
sleep ours
to come and drink  so much
Pisan omnipotence Deus as much as it
resembles hidden seen or you always
desiring that and becoming church
lends to this museum
here that obstacle omnes came firecrackers and
in the believers a witness dies
a work a precipient who are a true
our cousins ​​of slamming gaudian
confteri  for Christ does not sleep our
Omnibus Republic not moderates
[Music]
according to a volunteer
Omni Potenza Piceno Zeus in kuries but they
are not Tony exported
Nino sadeos chinòs impotentate moderate
Oblique and Terrano a little fear not
prosperity peace and securitas religions yes
Libertas  of silver and costism for
Christ Domi our
oramus Pro peoples spelloro matrocitati
broken buses
no
tears sanguiss
victimarum is founding original
seat three sedetatem properen Pacis
exesu Cristi gloriose
vulneribus Manente I must
be resorted to Fortis more beautiful with
interista and primisco and superbus
immanitati sabomanano gener lacrima
mark fesinante the archer
In truth your nominations children Me li
amor per Cristo un dominus
[Music]
mistakes bossmorbidafera
[Music] [
Music]
every time a simple neovirus I am
a Consulate work in fortitude to
come to you precise I say Anyway
tiburazione  clamazion or tonsivi
need type Swift Mercy
Antoine ghauerant buy because they are
dominates our
[Music]
[Music] [
Music] [Music] [Music] [Music] [Music] [Music] [Music] [Music] [Music]
[Music  ]
[Music]
revolves around
I can't make it grow
in your
world
always black that when it
has to be footprints
[Music]
full [
Music] [
Music] I
don't know
[Music] [Music]
[Music]
[  Music]
[Music
] [Music] [Music
] [
Music] [
Music]
Santa Croce
[Music] [Music
]
[Music]
recepti salutebus moniti e divine
institution formats
[Music] [
Music]
money money
in the moment
Sometimes it opens YouTube for me
up to Bologna
which begins
in our group of Tirano
the money
credits
when I will go
right into mythical religions does not
suffer
and getting lost in all this is understood yes
to live they are not
liberanosse this mus Domine to men
Mus malis
da propitius Pacem indiebus our
utopies Mercy  and you help
age Sin Simo always free and taboni
perturbation securi ex duente
sbeatam spem and tadventure salvatorius
nostri Jesus Christ Superstar [
Music]
Ecce agnus dei
exquitollit peccata Mundi Beati qui a
cena Agni vocati sunt o donne non sul
virus [Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
here I opened
the center
a relationship you breathe in
[Music]
I think
[Music] I'm
coming I'm coming I'm coming [
Music] [
Applause] [Music] [Applause
]
[Music]
[Applause]
[  Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause] [
Music] [
Music]
I too have opened
[Music]
2003 great great breath of the world
eternal omnipotence
death at the resurrection separated
Preserve the new Opus mercies 2
mysteries of  participation for price
substitutions we lived for this dominus
inclined
forced blessing
superpolonton this musomile that died
in your children and often and Resurrection
second
blessing copious descendant hesitation
Venier console yourself and tribute fidesanta on
grow
silent for Christian Domino Our
father